♪ ♪
>> Bret: BREAKING TONIGHT AS
WE MENTIONED MY COLLEAGUE
HARRIS FAULKNER SAT DOWN WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP MOMENTS AGO
WRAPPING THAT INTERVIEW UP IN
DALLAS.
WE HOPE TO SPEAK TO HER ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO A PIECE OF
THIS.
LET’S TAKE IT.
>> Harris: THE POINT WHERE YOU
FEEL WHAT THE PROTESTERS, IT IS
HEARTBREAKING.
>> President Trump: IT IS
TERRIBLE.
>> Harris: AND IT IS ALSO FEAR
THAT THINGS MAY NOT CHANGE.
THERE WILL BE SOME WHO ARE
VULNERABLE, PEOPLE OF COLOR, THE
POWER IMBALANCE.
YOU TALK ABOUT SOME ON SOME
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
YOU AND I ARE IN AGREEMENT 19%
OF POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
U.S. ARE FORMER MILITARY.
AND YOU KNOW THAT TOUCHES ME.
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT HOW WE FIX
IT, TALK TO ME ABOUT POLICE
REFORM.
YOU CALL YOURSELF THE LAW AND
ORDER PRESIDENT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> President Trump: WELL, WE
ARE GOING TO DO LOTS OF THINGS.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO KEEP OUR
POLICE AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
STRONG.
THEY HAVE TO DO IT RIGHT.
THEY HAVE TO BE TRAINED IN A
PROPER MANNER.
THEY HAVE TO DO IT RIGHT.
AGAIN, THE SAD THING IS THEY ARE
VERY PROFESSIONAL.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE AN EVENT LIKE
THAT, MORE THAN 8 MINUTES OF
WAR, THAT IS 8 MINUTES OF HORROR
AND DISGRACE.
AND THEN PEOPLE START SAYING,
WELL TOMORROW PLEASE LIKE THAT?
THEY DON’T KNOW?
MAYBE THEY DON’T THINK ABOUT IT
THAT MUCH.
IT DOESN’T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE.
THE POLICE ARE LIKE THAT.
THE POLICE ARE NOT LIKE THAT.
I HAVE SEEN SO MANY INCREDIBLE
THINGS THEY DO, BUT YOU DON’T
SEE THAT.
YOU DON’T PUT IT ON FOX.
YOU DON’T PUT ON TELEVISION.
>> Harris: I DO HAVE A POLICE
TOWN HALL SO I DO.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE I SEE?
WE HAVE ASKED OUR OFFICERS TO DO
SO MUCH HERE THEY ARE SOLVING
OUR HOMELESS ISSUES.
THEY ARE SOLVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLS WHICH
CAN BE ABSOLUTELY UNPREDICTABLE
WHEN YOU PUT THAT MUCH HUMAN
EMOTION TOGETHER.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE CAN’T
LOSE WITHOUT THEM FEELING READY.
THE SUICIDE RATES ARE UP AMONG
POLICE OFFICERS PARTICULARLY IN
NEW YORK.
AND SO WE KNOW THE ISSUES ARE
THERE.
>> President Trump: IT IS A
TOUGH JOB COMPARISON.
AND THE POLICE OFFICER STANDING
ON A CORNER AND THEY GET
STABBED.
IN THAT CASE BY A TERRACE LAST
WEEK.
HOW BAD WAS THAT?
WHAT IS THIS ALL ABOUT?
WE HAVE SEEN SOME TERRIBLE
THINGS HAPPEN TO POLICE
OFFICERS.
THERE IS ALSO, AND YOU KNOW,
THERE IS THAT LINE, BUT MOST OF
THE POLICE OFFICERS ARE REALLY
GOOD PEOPLE.
>> Bret: JOINING US NOW FROM
DALLAS IS MY COLLEAGUE,
HARRIS FAULKNER WHO JUST WRAPPED
UP THE INTERVIEW.
>> Harris: HI, BRET.
>> Bret: IS THAT AMOUNT OF
TIME, GOOD EVENING, HERE IS,
TELL ME THE AMOUNT OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU ASKED AND WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
>> Harris: SO YOU KNOW, I
THINK THE PRESIDENT IS QUITE
USED TO TALKING ABOUT THE
POLITICS AT THE MOMENT, BRET,
YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT IN THIS MOMENT, THERE WAS NO
GETTING AROUND THE QUESTION
LOOKED A LOT LIKE THE PROTESTERS
IN THE STREET.
AND I MADE THE POINT OF PUTTING
THAT OUT THERE.
I DON’T NORMALLY, BUT I THINK IT
IS WORTH SOMETHING BECAUSE YOU
CAN’T JUST CALL THEM RIOTERS.
HE AND I TALKED ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO THEM?
ONE OF THE THINGS I ASKED HIM
CAN YOU BE THE LAW AND ORDER
PRESIDENT -- I DID ASK HIM WHAT
HE MEANT BY THAT AND HE DID TALK
ABOUT THAT -- BUT CAN YOU BE THE
CHIEF?
HE THINKS THEY ARE ONE IN THE
SAME AND IF YOU GET TOO SOFT,
YOU CANNOT LEAD.
AND THOSE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT
TO KNOW ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE ONE
PRESIDENT AT A TIME.
AND WE WANT TO KNOW HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO DEAL WITH THE MOMENT
THAT I DESCRIBED TO THE
PRESIDENT OFF AT THE TOP OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT HISTORY MAY
LOOK BACK ON FUTURE GENERATIONS
AND RATHER LOOK BACK ON THIS
HISTORICAL MOMENT AND WONDER WHO
WE WERE.
AND I WANTED TO KNOW, IS HE THE
PRESIDENT THAT CAN UNITE US?
THAT IS WHERE THE CONVERSATION
WENT.
WE TALKED ABOUT GENERAL MILLEY
AND THE PUSH BACK ON THAT NOW
INFAMOUS PHOTOGRAPH AT LAFAYETTE
SQUARE.
AND HOW HE FELT ABOUT THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE ALSO TAKING
EXCEPTION AND APOLOGIZING AND
REGRETTING THAT PHOTO.
HE SAID IT WASN’T SIGNIFICANT TO
HIM THAT THEY TOOK EXCEPTION,
AND THAT HE STILL THINKS IT IS A
GREAT MOMENT FOR HIM AND HIS
PRESIDENCY.
SO WE TALKED ABOUT THOSE ISSUES.
WE LISTENED.
COMING OUT OF A PRETTY
HEIGHTENED EVENT HERE AND A
MEGA-CHURCH IN DALLAS, GATEWAY.
>> Bret: VERY QUICKLY, HARRIS.
DO YOU SENSE -- AND HE HASN’T
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
FRUSTRATION, THE ANCHOR, THE
FEAR IN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP TAPPED INTO
THAT AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
HE TOLD YOU.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, I THINK
WHAT HE TAPPED INTO AND I CAN
ONLY SAY THIS.
I SHOULDN’T SAY I THINK, I KNOW
WHAT HE TAPPED INTO BECAUSE HE
MENTIONED MORE THAN ONCE.
HE WATCHED THE 8 MINUTES AND 46
SECONDS HE SAID OF GEORGE
FLOYD’S DEATH.
HE TAPS INTO THE LOSS AND THE
HURT AND PAIN.
AND HE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
I THINK WHERE WE WERE KIND OF
PRESSING BACK AND FORTH IN OUR
CONVERSATION WAS WITHIN DO YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR THEM TO HEAR FROM YOU IN
THIS MOMENT FROM THAT CHEAP
PERSPECTIVE?
I DON’T KNOW THAT THAT IS AS
IMPORTANT TO HIM AS HIS
PERSPECTIVE.
HE THINKS THAT FIXING THE
ECONOMY IS HOW YOU BRING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND BRING
THEM FORTH.
HE WANTS TO RESTORE THE WORKINGS
OF BLACK WEALTH AND THAT RISE,
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES ECONOMICALLY.
THAT IS HOW HE WANTS TO GO
FORWARD.
IT WAS A FASCINATING
CONVERSATION TO GET IN THERE
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND SEE WHERE
HE IS.